ben je pense d'abord qu'il aurait fallu
tout faire pour qu'on ne se retrouve pas
dans une situation où on doive en
arriver là et le président de la
république il avait fait un pari il dit
lui même il a dit on va faire un pari
c'est vous qui avait essayé de ne pas
confiné et aujourd'hui parce qu'on
observe c'est qu'il a perdu son pari
puisqu'il va confiné et pourquoi il a
perdu son pari parce qu'un président de
la république c'est pas là seulement
pour faire des paris pour observer la
situation c'est là pour agir pour
essayer de faire en sorte d'agir sur la
situation et a mon avis il l'a pas fait
nous on avait mis sur la table depuis
six mois de ce qu'on avait appelé des
alternatives au confinement pour ne pas
devoir se retrouver à ce que vous pouvez
les rappeler relation rapide ma exemple
monsieur disait à juste titre on a
maintenant la certitude que dans les
écoles effectivement c'est un facteur de
contamination moi je suis pas pour
fermer les écoles mais on aurait pu
faire en sorte de généraliser les deux
micros partout par exemple au collège
par exemple à l'école si tu vas trophées
leaders et qui sait ce qui va être des
gens font ils ça veut dire organiser la
société sous forme de roulement il ya
des gens qui travaillent davantage le
matin des gens qui travaillent davantage
l'après midi plutôt qu'un couvre-feu qui
fait que entre 17h et 18h bas tout le
monde se retrouve dans les transports
tout le monde se retrouve au centre
commercial pour aller faire les courses
ça veut dire un vrai dispositif
d'isolement qui n'a pas été fait ça fait
depuis un an qu'on nous dit testez tracé
isolé d'ailleurs ça a tellement été mal
fait monsieur que maintenant vous
appelez même plus à tester tracé isolé
vous assurons répondre à ces projets
parce que ça avait été un fiasco total
donc voila moi je suis ce que je
regrette ce qu'on se retrouve dans une
situation où par manque d'anticipation
une nouvelle fois on est au pied du mur
comme ça a été le cas sur les masses
comme ça a été le cas sur les tests et
on se retrouve à devoir dire aux
françaises et aux français c'est vous
qui allez payer la facture ben moi j'ai
pas d'accord avec ça sacha ollier député
la république en marge de la vienne
alors il ya une règle ici tout le monde
est de bonne foi et je vous ai entendu
protester comme monsieur bompard a parlé
de paris de la part du présent la pub
excusez moi c'est la vérité pure il a
fait un pari sur la récente l'absence de
confinement mais oui bien sûr l'argent
je rencontre mes sûr est de besoin non
mais t'as fini juste je note
factuellement que ce pari est perdu
voilà et il ya une question qui a été
posée aux chroniqueurs qui ont répondu
oui ou non
est-ce que c'était la bonne solution
leur confinement fallait-il reconfirmer
strictement guérison de confiner
monsieur oublier la parole d'abord c'est
de l'art et pour les cyniques qui
pensent qu'on a échoué pour nous c'est
d'édition politique et un moment donné
on a dit
l'incidence oui ou non elle permet où
elle nous oblige à recombiner la réponse
à l'époque était non et donc le temps
qui a été gagnée avec un fonctionnement
normal
en tout cas moins anormales possibles
sur l'économie sur les scolaires et donc
sur les écoles les collèges qui par
ailleurs les collèges sont parfois en
jauge derrière les lycées sont parfois
aussi en jauge prévu des aménagements
non mais il ya des arrangements locaux
lorsque la situation le nécessite et la
situation aujourd'hui ce n'était pas un
pari c'est une décision politique parce
qu'il ya une adaptation territoriales on
traite pas la france partout pareil on a
des des zones dans lesquelles
l'incidence a dépassé de 400 on avait
dit quand l'incident dépasser 4 sans les
mesures nouvelles seraient nécessaires
dans mon département on a une incidence
à 190 et dans d'autres départements si
vous allez dans les pyrénées atlantiques
où dans le finistère où en tant que vous
êtes en incidence 50 est ce qu'on peut
dire que dans ces départements là le
pari gagné pas plus parce que ce sont
des décisions et on applique des
décisions qui correspondent à des
situations locales à chaque fois et le
but c'est de gérer l'épidémie pour que
et le moins de personnes possible en
réanimation et qui est le plus personnes
possibles qui vivent avec des conditions
qui soient le plus correct et donc avec
des enfants qui vont à l'école avait des
antilles si ces gens qui vont travailler
avec des gens qui ont accès à des
services qui soient finalement les
fonctionnels